ce que l'adn nous dit c'est que
visiblement c'est des populations qui
viennent de sibérie et qui sont aller
petit à petit est là encore ça prend
quelques milliers d'années et qui sont
aller coloniser l'amérique ce qui fait
que les amérindiens actuelle en main en
amérique descendent essentiellement de
ses premières migrations de gens qui
sont venus donc parle détroit de béring
vous savez ce qui relie la russie et
l'amérique et petit à petit son arrivée
là bas il ya 15 20 mille ans ce qui est
surprenant que ce qu'on aurait des
traces archéologiques plus anciennes
notamment en amérique du sud donc
peut-être qu'il ya eu des arrivées avant
mais qui n'ont pas laissé de descendance
génétique jusqu'à nos jours en tous les
cas le gros du pool génique et est venue
de ces migrations de 15 20 mille ans les
premiers qui peuplent l'amérique
on peut le dire puisqu'on est sur rt
c'était des russes hier fabien plus
quand on est allé sur le terrain en
sibérie et qu'on a pu rencontrer des
autorités pour leur expliquer qu on
retrace est dans l'adn nous emmenait et
on leur disait c'est grâce à l'adn qu'on
a pu retracer que finalement l'amérique
a été colonisé par les jambes de sibérie
autrement dit par ma part des russes à
ça leur a bien plu
ils ont eu plus de mal quand on leur a
expliqué convoler aussi retracé les
mouvements issus d'afrique et que aussi
venaient d'afrique
[Musique]